la ville d'elancourt lance aujourd'hui 8
avril sa semaine du handicap plusieurs
rendez vous jusqu'à samedi à destination
notamment des plus jeunes bernadette
pilloy bonsoir vous étiez ce matin
l'école maternelle de la ville duel en
cours avec dakota c'est votre chien
guide qui vous accompagnent d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau puisque vous êtes mal
voyantes comment s'est passée les
changes avec les enfants ce matin et
comme d'habitude j'ai été très bien
reçue et ma venue avec mon chien était
bien préparée par la maîtresse je suis
venu avec un certain nombre de jeux
tactiles pour des activités avec les
enfants avec ma poupée fétiche et sans
char à l'écran mais ça ne va pas tarder
et une fois de plus j'ai pu constater à
quel point les enfants sont de
merveilleux acteurs de la rencontre avec
des personnes handicapées un exemple
touchant la maîtresse m'a dit que quand
elle avait annoncé ma visite un certain
nombre d'enfants védiaud oui mais on a
peur des chiens et ce matin aucun des
enfants n'a eu peur de mon chien bien
préparée par la maîtresse ouvert à la
différence ces enfants m'ont posé des
questions bien plus intelligente que la
plupart des élus et à chaque fois ci
nous souhaitons est la demande de la
mairie des d'elancourt aller à la
rencontre de ce jeune public c'est pour
qu'ensuite ses enfants soit nous en nos
ambassadeurs qu'il parle de nous de nous
personne handicapée à leurs parents et
oui c'est très positif tous les ans
quelles sont les questions justement
vous pose ses enfants alors se
rappellera cette semaine est organisée
dans le cadre d'une semaine du handicap
s'est organisée par la ville d'elancourt
c'était sur une des écoles mais ces
quelques enfants vous avez alors avec
qui vous avez changé vous on pose est
quel type de quel est le type de
questions c'est d'abord dont je porte
des victoires et est ce qui est très
important pour eux c'est de savoir si
j'ai des yeux oui c'est ma rétine qui
est abîmée donc j'ai des yeux donc je
leur montre que j'ai dès que j'ai des
yeux et et il me demande mais comment ça
se passe et à quoi à quoi il sert ton
chien et donc je leur montre en général
il ya un parcours d'obstacles dans la
classe et
ils sont très admiratif et ils sont
touchés par le fait que je ne me cogne
jamais ils remarquent alors tu te donnes
pas avec ton chien bon je leur montre
que dakota c'est me trouver un siège à
saissac ton chien sait faire puis alors
c'est toujours les mêmes questions que
ça c'est le même que les adultes
pourront qui fait pour ta bille et
comment tu fais pour se laver comme
motif et pour manger toujours les mêmes
questions qui reviennent et vous répéter
inlassablement les mêmes réponses parce
que ça fait partie de votre travail je
rappelle que vous êtes la secrétaire de
l'association nationale des maîtres
chiens guides d'aveuglés vous travaillez
aussi à cette sensibilisation permanente
aussi bien des enfants que des adultes
parce que ce sont les adultes qui sont
aussi touchés via les enfants alors on
essaye de parler aux enfants qui sont
plus ouverts que beaucoup d'adultes
parce qu'une loi nous autorise elle est
partout avec notre chien guide et
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore le
cas on vient de faire une grande enquête
on a remis ce matin une pétition avec 31
mille signatures
madame car l'outil la ministre chargée
du handicap parce que la loi n'est pas
encore bien connus et dans cette enquête
on a pu constater que en moyenne à
maîtres de chiens guides essuie un refus
par semaine et c'est beaucoup parce que
c'est toujours pour nous une souffrance
et nous renvoyer à notre handicap de
nous dire ne vous rentrez pas vous avez
un chien vous rentrez pas alors que
depuis 2005 et cette loi existe les
chiens guides d'aveuglés qui sont vos
yeux au quotidien peuvent circuler
librement partout avec vous dans tous
les lieux publics dans les centres
commerciaux les transports les taxis les
écoles les écoles également puisqu'ils
ont été d'ailleurs ce matin concrètement
quel risque légal légalement pour les
personnes qui s'opposent qui vous refuse
les refuse l'accès attaques s'inscrivent
donc c'est quand même 150 euros damende
la première fois 450 euros en cas de
refus mais dans le cadre de mon
association je suis chargé de régler ses
problèmes de refus et c'est pour ça
qu'on fait cette grande campagne de
sensibilisation partout et on répond
toujours aux demandes comme celle de la
mairie d'elancourt c'est que si les gens
savent est qu'il ya une exception pour
les chiens guides il n'y aurait plus de
problème
moi ce que je souhaite que ce que mon
association souhaite c'est pas le
conflit s'est pas l'amande c'est
simplement que cette exception soit
connue et que nous puissions aller
librement comme tout le monde avec notre
chère notent qu'un guide notre chien ce
sont nos yeux on n'est pas nos yeux la
porte il ya une petite difficulté
supplémentaire aussi pour ses chiens qui
vous accompagnent ce sont à ceux qui
sont en formation les plus jeunes à qui
on apprend à les mêmes droits est ce que
vous demandez aussi longue qu'on me
demande ça parce que l'accès libre du
chien est liée à notre carte
d'invalidité donc le chien guide c'est
le chien qui accompagne une personne qui
a une carte d'invalidité mais pour que
nos chiens sacha aller partout il faut
que au cours de leur éducation pendant
qu'ils sont dans une famille d'accueil
dans sur saint quentin en yvelines il y
a plusieurs familles d'accueil bénévoles
avec un dévouement extraordinaire qui
prépare nos chiens ailleurs travail les
éducateurs des écoles de chiens guides
plus ils pourront aller partout avec nos
futurs chiens plus l'éducation de nos
chiens sera bien fait donc on demande
l'extension du statut du chien guide aux
chiens en éducation nous sommes en
pleine semaine du handicap sur la ville
d'elancourt vous êtes intervenu ce matin
dans une des écoles il y aura d'autres
échanges de programmes et vendredi matin
voilà ça va également se passer mais
avec des plus grands la victoire du
grand old harry mais elle prit m et vous
en attendez quoi j'en attend d'abord à
un plaisir personnel énorme parce que
j'adore les enfants que j'ai neuf petits
enfants alors 28 ou 30 de plus je trouve
ça super et je j'attends surtout de ses
contacts que la personne handicapée quel
que soit son handicap soit avant tout
considéré comme une personne pense que
c'est très important pour nous que
derrière notre handicap on voit que nous
sommes des personnes et vous avez le
sentiment que le message passe vous qui
chaque année et revenait sur ses semaine
du handicap qui règne à rencontrer
régulièrement ses enfants ses plus
jeunes je suis sans doute une optimiste
invétéré mais si j'étais pas optimiste
je ferai pas tout ce que je fais je
trouve que les choses s'améliorent quand
même merci bernadette pilloy écrivain
public également vous intervenez dans le
cadre de la semaine du handicap à
elancourt auprès de ces jeunes des
élèves et le prochain échange est prévu
vendredi c'est l'école élémentaire du
gant douget merci à vous votre rendez
vous aussi à signaler qu'ils s'adressent
à tous cette fois ci c'est l'élan
signent jeudi à partir de 19 heures une
rencontre pour découvrir à la langue des
signes c'est à la ferme du mousseau un
échange avec des personnes
malentendantes qui vous guideront dans
la découverte ou l'apprentissage de ces
codes de l'opération élan signes
existent d'ailleurs depuis deux ans sur
la commune ce type de réunions se
déroulent chaque mois avec l'association
socioculturelle et des sourds de saint
quentin en yvelines vous en apercevez à
quelques images que nous réalisés lors
du lancement justement de ce qu'a fait
signe à l encours le programme complet
de la semaine du handicap et sur le site
de la ville d'elancourt nous continuons
à parler de ces questions de société on
va parler du sida à présent on va
débriefer ces dons qui sont en hausse
pour le sidaction 2013